[Music]
so my name's ben vereen i'm just looking
the cloud seam have been all over my
slides that cloud in the corner was
actually an android robot this morning
and my my job actually work in android
not Google cloud so they've they've
changed a few things but anyway I know
that this is a cloud conference but we
thought we'd set up shop here and run a
few sessions on Android in particular
Android enterprise
so you know thank you for thank you for
coming along
typically we announce Android related
things at Google i/o so there'll be a
lot more activity in around woman's time
so yeah I head up the Android Enterprise
engineering division
I'm racially based out of London Android
is actually built in two locations most
of its here in Mountain View but there
are also some significant engineering
teams in London as well so today we're
going to look at privacy I say purposes
I'm British I try switching to privacy
but I couldn't do consistently so if you
don't understand privacy equals privacy
so how privacy can benefits IT and
employees and some of the unique
features we have in Android that we've
introduced recently and also just to
give you a feeling for where Android is
going in the enterprise so as you know
privacy has never been more important
not only as the legal landscape change
with things like gdpr and so on but also
people's attitudes towards technology
and privacy as technology plays a
increasingly important role in people's
lives so when we talk to customers we
consistently hear about this tension
between secure and always-on and private
and the ability to detach from work and
this is exaggerated in BYOD devices
where users have a greater expectation
over privacy
and it's in this tension that we we felt
there's an opportunity in Android for IT
to enable security whilst also enabling
employee privacy especially on BYOD
devices so you could ask you know is
this is this just a problem that the
valley has and we're solving it for
other people in the valley is this some
kind of touchy-feely problem or is there
a real opportunity in actually solving
the solving the privacy problem when
we're talking to customers privacy
consistently comes up as the number one
reason why mobile deployments have
friction meaning adoption of BYOD isn't
what companies expect and this is also
shown on the slide here in the 2018 IDC
survey Android actually has a unique
mode to deal with this very issue and
it's one of my favorite features in
Android so we'll come on to that surely
so Android is helping companies make
mobility deployments successful we want
to change the dynamic between employees
and IT employees should feel empowered
and not burdened by technology with
something that is simple secure and
respectful but we also an IT to feel
empowered to increase privacy and
well-being without compromising on
security by decoupling these three
concepts and so with some of androids
unique offerings IT decision-makers can
actually advocate for their employees so
this is apparent dichotomy between
security and privacy can these truly be
separated such that having strong
security does not mean less privacy well
let's take a look so this is the typical
world of enterprise technology you know
patch tuesday marked on the calendar
gives IT the best chance of ensuring
devices are secure and running virus
scans are monitoring everything which is
happening on the device continuously
using typically third-party software
security is actually enabled through
visibility IT needs to know
about everything happening on the device
in order to ensure nothing insecure is
happening now mobile is increasingly
shifting away from this philosophy using
some emerging new security capabilities
yet a lot of assumptions around security
through visibility have carried on to
mobile yeah okay what's the virus
scanning solution for mobile phones and
how do I get visibility and see
everything which is happening on the
device we don't think that privacy needs
to be at the cost of great security we
also believe we also don't believe
device ownership should determine how
secure device can be there's no
universal law that says you can't have a
secure BYOD device it's simply down to
how we architect platforms now I'd see
how about challenging enough job as it
is enabling business use cases we don't
IT to have to worry about plugging gaps
in the platform itself we also don't
want you to have to worry about
installing third-party security
solutions and worrying about the patch
rate in a particular month to ensure
devices are secure so we're trying to
take trying to make sure that ownership
security and privacy can be configured
individually without the need for a
business to go to another vendor that it
sounds nice but how do we make sure that
yeah how do we do this in practice well
let's look at some of the arcades the
fundamental architecture of Android so
so first of all we have server-side
malware scanning so through Google Play
and managed place that manage plays a
version of Google Play which enterprises
can use to curate their own app store
and even push outs apps on two devices
update devices and manage their
configuration so anything that comes
through Google Play or manage Play first
of all will be scanned there and then
we've got Google Play protects for
device side scanning as well now Android
is actually built or was originally
built on top of se Linux and one of the
great benefits of SELinux is process
isolation which means that if something
insecure is happening on one of these
boxes so let's say one of these boxes
was a piece of malware or somehow some
malware got injected well it's more or
less its blast radius is more or less
impacted to the app itself and not
outside of that so this is kind of
process isolation so if the process
becomes compromised it can't gain access
to the space of another process and you
can also interrogate the operating
system so you can ask it you can ask it
questions like you know is the version
of the operating system that's running
on this device is it a official version
and that would be cryptographically
attested with the trusted boots using a
hardware root of trust so you can ask
questions like that you can ask simple
questions like you know is the password
on this device does it meet my criteria
for strong or has Google Play protect
flagged any issues so two things fall
out of this remarkably flexible
management and for the first time the
ability to remove conflict between
privacy and security so you don't need
to know what's going on inside one of
these boxes necessarily to know that the
overall device is secure so but you know
that that might not be enough to
convince you fair enough so let's look
at another feature this is my this is my
favorite feature in Android and it's
used heavily by Googlers but also many
other companies small and large so
something called work profile and the
way that I kind of explain this is it's
like having two phones in one piece of
hardware so on the on the right you can
see on your screen you've got a work tab
and on the Left you've got a personal
tab everything that goes on in anything
that goes on in your work or the work
side of your phone cannot access the
personal side and anything that happens
in the personal side cannot access the
work side so not only have you got this
these kind of boundaries between
processes themselves which I talked
about on the
it's slide but you've also got this kind
of almost two virtual phones running
inside this phone and so and that
separation is enforced at the OS level
which means that multiple
vulnerabilities would have to be
exploited for something personal on in a
personal profile so anything acts as
anything in the work profile both
application sandboxing and the OS
security boundary between these two
areas so in the traditional world this
this would have broken you know if you
can't see what's happening on the
personal side of the phone well how do
you know whether the device is secure
well the kind of Android stance on this
is it doesn't matter because you know
what happens on the personal side can't
access the work side there
they're almost like two separate phones
and even from the work site you can ask
the OS questions about the overall
security stance of the device so you can
ask you to are there are there any
insecure or untoward apps on this phone
anywhere and it will tell you the answer
to that by looking in the person and
we're profile without breaching the
trust of the user and then you can take
action as a result of that as well so
which is usually configured to be
automatic like you do wipe wipe wipe out
the web profile and so you get these
kind of strong level OS assurances that
the device is in a good security posture
meaning direct visibility is not needed
to ensure security hence whatever the
user is doing in their personal profile
remains private you know you come you
can't look at network logs or anything
like that from the personal side and and
yet companies are able to control and do
whatever they want within the work side
of the phone and if you really wanted to
put virus scanning on there and the work
side you absolutely could
so ite only manages and views apps in
the work profile personal data is stored
separately IT can arrays the work
profile or apps and data ID cants view
or arrays personal data
it's literally like having two friends
in one phone now if you're if you're
provisioning a device on BYOD so let's
say you bring your own device to work
the typical flow the thing that happens
is you you enter your work email address
and password
you had an account and if you've
configured work profile it will say
either you have the option to have a
work profile or you must have a work
profile depending on what you set the
user can then the device will then
automatically create that separate space
for you that separate work profile that
separate phone within a phone so I think
you know the takeaway from that from
this section is you consider enabling
where profile especially for reasons of
privacy for your employees and you you
almost certainly find that you're a BYO
adoption goes up so we believe this is
the the modern approach to mobile
security which enables privacy and helps
eliminate the lack of certainty which
was often a deployment blocker in a lot
of places a lot of places employee
confidence they know that data belongs
to them and what they're and they know
what their employer can and can't see
and because these are separate data
stores if the employee leaves or the
account is compromised the work data can
be wiped without losing personal data so
the risks so reduces the risks
associated with a personal data loss and
because it's clear what is work and what
is personal users don't have this kind
of scary unknown question around what
you know whether they're allowed to be
doing certain things on the device or
being uncertain about what the company
may or may not be able to see so think
about the atmosphere around user data
privacy GD P R and the Year in the EU
this is a chance for that the Android is
a platform to enable I'd see to allowing
business interests with employee
interests and an opportunity for IT to
get ahead of emerging expectations
around this technology
so we covered the privacy security
trade-off but another trade-off that we
talked about this is kind of double
edged sword with always-on connectivity
that promise that yeah now you can work
from anywhere this kind of mobile
workforce being the mantra of enterprise
deployments well that's great until it's
time not to be working and everything is
still running on your device so let's
look at how we're trying to separate the
notion of mobility and always-on we've
talked to lots we talked to a lot of
users and the responses have been
amusing and concerning so my my phone is
the first thing I look at when I wake up
I think probably a lot of people in this
room can relate to that
I certainly can yeah if I don't respond
in 30 minutes people think I've died oh
gosh this is a true story
so someone went hiking for the day and
didn't set their out-of-office
notification on their calendar they
didn't have connectivity and they didn't
respond to a message within three hours
and their colleagues called the police
and reported him as a missing person
it's kind of ridiculous isn't it my
phone has become a dictator so the
device which is supposed to be enabling
us actually becomes a ball and chain
it's that double-edged sword of
connectivity and well-being so as a
society we haven't caught up with how to
manage this and the tools haven't caught
up with human behavior frankly users
don't have a way to filter or mitigates
this always-on reality we now live in
android is taking this problem very
seriously and is starting to address him
so we introduced the concept of digital
well-being in Android in Google i/o last
spring and you know we kind of concept
behind this is we don't want phones
ruling our lives they should be
improving lives and making workers more
productive
certainly not distracting us from the
most important things
so we're starting to introduce some
features to advance this so we
previously introduced I proofs to
introduce work profile now one of the
benefits I didn't talk about at the time
was well because there's kind of
essentially two fans in one phone you
can switch one of the phones off so you
can switch your you can switch your work
phone off and that means that yeah
everything on there is gone literally
nothing nothing can drain your battery
in the background you know can sync
there's no notifications from from any
of your any of your work apps and
actually I use this feature all the time
so you know late in the evening I tend
to switch my work profile off and then I
when I wake up in the morning with kind
of like you know when I looking at my
phone I don't get like a bunch of work
emails I switch that back on when I'm
ready and other people you know switch
that off for weekends and other things
because we know now because we've got
this profile we know what a work app
some more time because where your work
apps are in your work side of your phone
you can just switch that work side of
and actually the interesting thing it
doesn't quite work quite like this
animation so when you switch it back on
because the cryptographic key is being
thrown away it will actually ask you for
your PIN again because again it has to
login to that phone so so if I did the
ability we thought so we've so you've
got the kind of work profile switch
switch one enough that's one digital
well-being thing we've added the ability
to let you see how to spend time on your
device by by giving users date so we can
help them become more aware of their
habits you yeah often what happens to me
at least is I get a identification that
an email comes in so I you know open my
phone app to respond to that and then I
get another notification from from
social media and before I know it I've
spent ten minutes scrolling up social
media and I've completely forgotten why
I unlock that device in the first place
so we want to make sure that the time
you spend on your device is high quality
time by giving your visibility and
providing controls so first in terms of
awareness we've introduced a dashboard
which gives you a snap
lots of of your digital habits with
three metrics so you've got your your
screen time mm-hmm
so how you spend that which apps you are
in in the most and so on and then how
many times you've only look to your
phone often we we don't realize actually
how much time how often we we do that in
a day and how many notifications you
received so how much how which apps are
distracting you the most so on the left
here you'll see how your day breaks down
on what you spend your time on and if
you tap for further information you can
see trends over time and aspect this is
especially useful if you're trying to
change your habits you can actually see
well if you don't am I actually changing
my habits by looking at these trends and
for the apps that you want to be mindful
of we've introduced app timers and so
once you've once you've used the amount
of time you've allotted for that app the
Apple gray outs and will be paused for
the rest of the day and so anyway
getting notifications from that app
either so we've all experienced how
distracting these devices can be sitting
down in a meeting getting a notification
you know often that happens so several
people in the meeting and of course the
the devices in this case interacting
with us when when we actually don't once
it see we don't want to be distracted
we're animating and so we've introduced
gestures one of them is flipped to shush
so if you flip your phone over it won't
when distract you it won't make any
notification sounds or ring if there's
if there are incoming calls so that this
is on the latest pixel devices and
another a number of other devices from
various OMS the other feature we've
introduced is wind down so lack of sleep
caused a four hundred billion dollar
productivity head so your companies in
the US in 2016 according to a study and
for many people in this room that's
of millions of dollars so and we sort of
realized that you know getting pinged at
11 p.m. probably isn't helping with that
and because sleep is really important
and can keep us from getting enough
we've introduced this wine down feature
so wind down sets of schedule to remind
you of when to switch off at night so
you said a bedtime for your phone and it
fades to grayscale and sets sets itself
to do not disturb so you went it will
silence notifications it's still
completely usable and allows you to
finish up whatever you were doing but
our studies have shown that it's a lot
less engaging and distracting so it's
much harder to get stuck in that lot in
that sort of infinite scroll or a video
so it's a important part of our
well-being story it's early days and
Android will continue to invest in
digital wellbeing both from a consumer
and enterprise perspective users tell us
that these types of features are helping
them to change behavior and it's a real
opportunity for IT departments to
champion these things and raise
awareness with their employees so we'll
continue to invest in wellbeing for
consumer and enterprise something that
we're working on actively right now is
in app switching so so if you were for
example using Gmail in your personal
profile and you want to change accounts
to your work profile to reply to emails
there you can do that from within the
app and it will actually sort of
seamlessly switch out the personal and
work version of the app so working on
that will continue to invest in Android
as a platform you know you may or may
not know but Android is actually a very
popular choice for line of business
applications so you know things like
kiosks or digital signage point-of-sale
rugged devices so in this sense Android
is both flexible and powerful and will
continue to invest in these things
on this later more so hopefully this has
given you a feel for where Android is
going and why Android is a great a great
choice for the needs of workers in 8c
and we've we've hope we hope that you've
seen how Android devices can be both
secure and respectful and as shown how
IT needs business needs and needs of
employees can all be aligned
[Music]